what happened today
no basically my background was open
and something like this
so I mean I didn't have a good opening
and so I was clearly West I was hoping
to tricky and he just grabbed a pawn
here so he played something like uh
something like this late Knight takes D6
and then I moved my queen to attack
at night but maybe I should play it here
to guard this Square
basically a move here and Ian gave a
check
and it never happened to me before but I
just assumed you can block with the Rook
I think some other players thought the
same but I think Michael thought the
same
apparently you can't do it because
making acid move yet further you could
just block it
but it's unchecked so clearly
I I just never really bothered to eat
fish around the world before in the past
I just play my feeling and really I
don't know
much about it but yeah I'm thinking a
bit about it now obviously though it
makes sense I mean the king is unchecked
so you gotta move The King and I
couldn't move the king because of my
point are here
basically you have to give up material
on the background mate
you just had to resign thank you so much